Speaker 1: All right, let's do a little bit
of follow up about what is the most disgusting
moment during any State of the Union address
that I can remember, and at this point, this
is an important story because it wasn't just
that Lauren Boebert heckled Joe Biden during
the State of the Union, and it wasn't just
that Lauren Boebert, radical Republican congresswoman,
heckled Joe Biden when Biden was talking about
his son, who died and served in the military
during the State of the Union. But it's about
the fact that so many Republicans are refusing
to condemn it. And it's about the fact that
many in right wing media are celebrating what
Lauren Boebert did, and it's absolutely and
completely disgusting. So let's start with
our first example. This is Republican Congressman
James Comer, who was given the opportunity
to condemn what Lauren Boebert did. Remember
Marjorie Taylor Greene also yelling out and
turning her back to Joe Biden? And he doesn't
do it. He doesn't do it. And it wouldn't be
that difficult to do it. You could do it in
a way where you that you still say, I mean,
listen, at this point, you could say, I completely
condemn what they did, but I also am worried
about x y z thing that Biden did right. Like,
it's pretty straightforward to put together
a statement like that. That's not what he
does. Look at. Look at this disgusting response.
Speaker 5: Congressman, before we let you
go, I do want to ask you about what we all
saw and heard. Frankly, last night from the
chamber, two of your colleagues, Lauren Boebert,
Marjorie Taylor Greene, were shouting at the
president throughout his speech at one moment
that I think a lot of people heard, she shouted
out 13 of them when the president was talking
about soldiers in a flag draped coffins. Do
you think that type of behavior is appropriate?
Speaker 2: Well, certainly whether you agree
or disagree with the president, I believe
during the State of the Union, we should all
show respect to the president. But honestly,
I
Speaker 1: but honestly, but honestly, this
is the same and we will get there. This is
like those tweets. Putin shouldn't invade
Ukraine, but and then something horrible follows
it,
Speaker 2: share their frustration when you
look at the crises that we're facing in this
country. It's pretty interesting.
Speaker 5: But should they be? Should they
be vocalizing that in the middle of his State
of the Union address? Does that not undercut
your party and its messaging on those critical
issues?
Speaker 2: It's certainly not my style. I've
heard that type of behavior from Democrats,
too when we had Republican presidents.
Speaker 1: No, actually. No, that's not true.
That's not true. There have the two main heckling
incidents are Joe Wilson heckling Barack Obama
and Boebert and Greene heckling Joe Biden.
Those are the incidents.
Speaker 2: Well, I just think that the best
across the aisle, Democrats yelled at a Republican
president of the chamber. When did that have?
Yeah. Well, when Donald Trump was was president.
So the thing that
Speaker 1: you know, that's not true.
Speaker 2: I think Congress should do is just
listen. And then we have an opportunity like
I'm doing now to speak to the America and
speak to the press about our disagreements
and move on.
Speaker 5: All right. Congressman James,
Speaker 1: so what do you guys think? I mean,
it's it's not like Boebert and Greene are
so prominent in the party leadership that
these are people that you can't be adversarial
with or whatever the case may be like, is
this is this guy a coward? Is he merely a
bad person? Like, what do you guys think is
the explanation? Because it's not exactly
a profile in courage, and it's even less likely
to be condemned when right wing media is sort
of cheerleading the entire thing. And that's
what I want to talk about next